hey good humans it's paulo you might
recognize my voice from odd one out and
that's because i directed the season
before we get into the video we want to
take a second to thank our sponsor atlas
vpn
internet security is a big deal these
days and atlas vpn is a super easy tool
that encrypts all the data you send and
hides your virtual location it's also
great for all kinds of daily life
situations you can use it to access
geoblock libraries on streaming services
like netflix amazon prime and hulu so
for example i'm a huge harry potter fan
but not all of the movies are available
in the us on netflix because of jio
restrictions and licensing agreements
but with atlas vpn in the few clicks i
can change my virtual address to canada
and
here we go harry potter
i think that is one of the coolest uses
but there's also tons of other benefits
to using atlas vpn you can get the best
deals on airline tickets and hotels
block malicious third-party links and
ads and increase your security on public
internet connections plus atlas vpn is
supported on any device and provides a
30-day money-back guarantee for all
subscription purchases of course we have
a great deal for you guys when you sign
up using the link below currently atlas
vpn is running a huge discount on their
three-year deal for just 139 per month
with a 30-day money-back guarantee the
deal won't last for long so make sure to
check it out by clicking the link in the
description below
thanks again to atlas vpn for sponsoring
this video hope you enjoyed the episode
when you stole the car or
we brought together seven people who
committed a crime i've committed a crime
i've committed a crime i've committed a
crime i've committed a crime i've
committed a crime i've committed a crime
i've committed a crime
one is an undercover cop if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
[Music]
so what is everybody's name and why
are you guys here my name is trina and
i'm here because i have duis
um i also have
a lot of traffic tickets i'm jeremiah
my convictions are receiving stolen
goods possession of paraphernalia drunk
in public and disturbing the peace i'm
andrew when i was 15 which is four years
ago i was arrested for tagging on
someone's walls my name was tequila and
one time as a juvenile i did a run out
in a store with a group of fans and it
led to an arrest my name is ricky uh
racing reckless striving and evading
okay my name is kenya and my last
conviction was
intended to fraud amisa i
also
got some got in some trouble with the
law for street racing in the beginning
he was sketchy like his mannerisms he
seemed a bit nervous what's everyone's
profession i wrap cars i do vinyl wraps
yeah for sure yeah
i'm sorry you're a cute yeah what's your
profession i'm curious i write books
write books okay okay
a second yeah okay i'm just trying to
look because a lot of cops have
conservative like style and i agree when
did you get your gta or whatever gta gta
it was actually this year didn't you say
it was gta
i noticed that trinach is kind of
accusing everybody else
just the way he was standing really
straight his build you know all cubs got
to be big
[Music]
i think because me being the only
african-american player it would be like
maybe he's the one maybe that's the
throw off we were going to say like what
everybody does for their profession well
i work at the california science center
i've been there for about two months i'm
a therapist i'm a barista i'm curious
that that when you stole the car
first of all
my mama watching days
sorry no allegedly
allegedly i apologize
not for sure but i was doing some street
racing cops are pretty conservative and
i'm curious because you guys straight
race how come you guys don't have any
tattoos i do i have mine are all anime
related so i got shenron right here the
anime checks out yeah what about chores
yeah i don't have tattoos because of
religious reasons eastside didn't have
any tattoos it didn't seem like he had
much of a criminal history that seemed
like it was really legitimate are those
real plugs or those are the ones that
are magnet they're magnets bro yeah good
question good question i had my
suspicion like why would someone want to
wear fake earrings so stretching your
ears hurts and afterwards they smell and
i'm very sensitive to smell so i gag did
anybody do like any gel time yeah i did
three months three months i was supposed
to do tears but i had a kid that was
really young and the judge kind of felt
bad with my health problems at the time
and so he went ahead and gave me a
weekend and i had to do that weekend and
then i was released
i did the two days
went to court what about you no i never
had to do jail
i personally didn't do any jail time
because the cop that pulled me over he
literally like is a regular at my job
and this dude like he was like bro and i
was like i'm so sorry dude like they
impound your car oh so he didn't he'd
even give you a conviction
he didn't he didn't take me in though
shout out
[Music]
i was so suspicious of eastside because
he was just two goody-goody
[Music]
we have a three-way tie
the tie is between isai
andrew and kenya i looked at myself in
the mirror when i got here and i was
like oh probably not the right outfit
for what i'm trying to portray each
person will get
20 seconds
to state your case february i was racing
got pulled over
march had court three months license
suspended one of my record all that i
mean that's the only thing i've ever
done though that's why like the cop
didn't take my car i've been driving
seven years prior to that and had no
tickets
so my criminal record is pretty
extensive but let's just start from my
last and final arrest i was arrested at
the bank and
i was cashing a check it was all bad i
did three and a half years it was not my
first conviction i had plenty of priors
i was just a tiger when i was like 15
so my freshman year i tagged someone's
house the cops caught me because it was
by my school luckily i didn't go to jail
because it was my first time being
arrested as a minor
so all they did was write me a ticket
for sure good luck guys
i don't have any tattoos and no
piercings so i guess they just don't put
it together please raise your hand
if you still have doubt and want to
continue playing the game
you guys were on the chopping block so
i'm curious like why do you think that
we would think that would be you too i
think i look too proper i don't dress
like this ever because i'm a
stay-at-home mom usually you'll find me
in sweats and like a t-shirt i think i'm
also dressed a little proper i have the
brogues
you know i think that's the most
expensive piece i have on me i'm sorry
i'm going to bring it back to the
earrings yeah if you're not a cop why
can't you just get the real plug i've
tried it and stretching your ears hurts
but not not at that gauge it doesn't i
just feel like i didn't think it was too
suspicious i thought maybe he just liked
the look what kind of drugs have you
done in your past maybe might still be
using and i'll go first dxm weed alcohol
basically i've tried almost everything i
don't like weed i don't like the smell
gives me a headache but i do drink so in
high school i started drinking alcohol i
became an alcoholic with my friends so i
overcame my addiction but every now and
then when i'm with my family i might
have the occasional drink he said he was
an alcoholic at such a young age i
thought that was a little weird i was
going to say even the street racing i
could see people still probably hiring
someone that because it's not like right
it's like a crime like there's no one
that gets hurt right so mine was on the
210 freeway going past pasadena i was
going like 110. i didn't see the cop he
was parked on the side
so you guys caught speeding
no but there was another it was an audi
a4 yeah when i passed by it took him a
while to catch up because he started
from nothing so they said i was evading
so that's that was like an additional
thing and that was like two thousand
dollars in fines my car got impounded
for 30 days and my license suspended was
for a year i'm thinking that the record
could still be looked good for the cops
though i think
[Music]
he seemed a little more quiet
goodbye y'all
bye
now i'm kind of bummed out cause my mom
was rooting for me
so i told her like i'm a win for you and
all that but
i mean it's cool please raise your hand
if you want to continue playing the game
in three
two one
how do you guys feel about
police oh good so i was gonna say what
do you what do you how do you guys feel
about a cab oh
a cab
do you know what that means what does it
stand for all cops are bad i thought it
was bastards yeah uh trina and jeremiah
were partnered up she got it wrong so as
soon as i saw that she got it wrong i
kind of just
try to scoot over and be a part of their
group i get anxiety just riding in the
car when a cop gets smaller right really
i i start sweating i forgot i started
like looking for my cigarette i don't
smoke
it's crazy
i don't like i'm so annoyed right
i know that there are good cops out
there but i think that we just see
because i mean if we're gonna be
realistic they're qualified
but i think that we see so many in the
media and stuff like that there are bad
abuse of power i'm not even comfortable
with like military people
i'm a military brat are you i feel like
they're different than cops a lot of
them come from war and then they turn
into police and there i'm not really too
sure where you stand now because where i
stand no no them in general oh i have a
question how do your parents feel about
that considering that you are a military
brat i grew up in a family so they kind
of like expected
us to kind of went astray gotcha
when she came at me i thought that was
odd because it wanted to divert
attention away from her how about you
yeah
so like the street racing was expected
[Music]
he could have been the one that was the
cop you know being that he was a
military brat
[Music]
i knew it
you guys [ __ ] up
like hard you guys [ __ ] up
good luck though please raise your hand
if you still want to continue playing
the game in three
two one
so why didn't you hit raise your hand
when you said continue to play you think
you already got that uh yeah i feel like
you guys are kind of like
straightforward for you i kind of felt
like the tattoos kind of like just
automatically ruled you out because i
feel like you can't have anything
showing i think what's alarming for me
with you is the fake yeah i feel you
that was the main thing yeah if someone
really wanted it and the style it would
be real right because then you don't
have to always have the magnet are you
technically in the medical field i'm in
the i'm a therapist is that considered
like the medical field psychology is
about the brain okay so because i know
that takes like a
a
kind of clean record i mean i can't
really think of anything other than that
at least my board of behavioral sciences
is very forgiving with things like that
i'm just thinking like because nurses
can't be a nurse if you have like a dui
so like but nurses are administering
medicine that's dangerous they could be
stealing the medicine right they can't
believe you can't do that then i'm a
therapist not a psychiatrist oh okay
okay okay that's where the mix-up was
trying to throw me off
[Music]
all right
i'm surprised i didn't get voted out
sooner because the whole earrings thing
if the light turns green that means you
have voted out the mole and you win
if the light turns red that means the
undercover cop is still in the box and
you lose
yes
[Music]
will the undercover cop please step
forward and reveal yourself in three
two one
go
i was definitely surprised that was the
only person that i trusted mainly
because of the similar crime been a cop
for like two years i love my job i get
to help a lot of people unfortunately
when i do get called i do see people on
their worst days i want to help people
but
not everybody's accepting that help you
can't really judge a book by its cover
but i mean for them i would have never
if i'd seen them working never would
have thought that any of them had either
been arrested anyone is capable of
committing a crime
but you have to learn from those things
and you have to try to be the better
person after you've made those mistakes
it took me to really sit down and look
at myself and where i didn't want to be
in life to pretty much change everything
up once you have a record or once you've
been to jail you know it's almost kind
of like
once a cheater always a cheater that's
not the case
hours
[Music]